they came to me from macys they'd seen
work a buying on Broadway and thought oh
this this looks like a balloon I mean
and it's true this is like I do inflated
forms so we dug around the studio came
up with an image I thought oh this
Humpty Dumpty image would be good after
he left the studio I room we were going
Oh upside down you know turn him in the
midst of falling seem to make sense with
the balloon it was great they've got it
like a toy land out in in New Jersey and
I loved going out there you know maybe a
hundred people working on these bizarre
balloons and models you start with a
small model and they scale up from there
and there's this all this you have to
change your design to fit the technology
of what balloons will do and can do so
that that was exciting and we actually
went out to South Dakota for the test
flight so we managed you know walked
with the balloon out there and then they
took me out enough a balloon ride around
South Dakota and then the macy's day
when the parade came we yeah it was
fabulous it's like a million people and
just on site and then the idea that
you're getting into 50 million homes
that that to me that was like I was
saying about trying to find avenues for
public work I thought that was that was
public work to get to get into TV sets
in 50 million homes that's how I first
knew New York was to watch the you know
in Kansas was to watch the Macy's Day
Parade so I knew what that felt like you
know that was a real deal